happy Friday I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Washington
tonight not everybody wealthy is a tax
cheat there's a whole hell of a lot of
it pot kettle black classic now you
heard the breaking news first right here
on the angle last night Hunter Biden
indicted again on nine new tax charges
including ah just three felony counts he
faces 17 years in prison for what the
doj is describing as a four-year scheme
to avoid paying
1.4 million in taxes prosecutors are
saying that he spent money on drugs
escorts girlfriends luxury hotels rental
properties exe exotic cars clothing and
other items well everything but his
taxes Hunter made a number of payments
using both his personal and his business
bank accounts to quote various women
totaling a staggering
$683,000
and he spent $188,000 on adult
entertainment now let's break down some
of these personal expenses a $1,500
venmo payment in 2018 to an exotic
dancer for what he called
artwork but she hadn't sold him many
that's strange he also paid an escort
nearly
$112,000 to spend two full nights with
him she should have charged more lucky
lady now we haven't even gotten to the
business expenses yet another exotic
dancer received
$773 in a venmo payment from Hunter
maybe I don't know Tango lessons they're
expensive these days he flew another one
across the country and spent tens of
thousands of dollars on hotel rooms many
of which were the same ones that he
named in his Memoir as the locations of
his month-long drug and alcohol beninge
again these were labeled as business
expenses
your son while there's no ties to you
could be charged by your Department of
Justice how will that impact your
presidency first of all my son's done
nothing wrong I trust him I have faith
in him and it impacts my presidency by
making me feel proud of him proud well
of the fact that Hunter also used the
business line of credit to make more
than
$27,000 in payments to an online porno
website in
2019 to your
[Music]
son I'm very proud of my son Hunters sto
paying spousal support to his ex-wife in
2018 that's a lot to be proud of despite
making $2.1 million that year he blame
tuition costs rent and oh yeah taxes you
know the ones he wasn't paying now at
one point that same ex-wife found
Hunter's unfilled tax returns they were
not even filled out in the trunk of his
car we have great confidence in our
son uh I am not concerned about any
accusations been made against him he is
the smartest man I know I mean in of
pure intellectual
capacity uh there's something pure uh I
thought we should suppose consider the
source on that one of course whenever
they're pressed about Hunter and
Hunter's Dian is Biden's Pals fall back
on his battle with addiction he loves
his son
um and uh he is proud of him overcoming
uh his addiction and how he's continuing
to build his life no one knows who he is
and then when you know the facts of him
it's actually sad you know a lot of
Americans are struggling with drug
addiction but like so much else
involving the bidens this was another
and probably one of the worst lies nice
tribe but prosecutors made very clear
that some of Hunter Biden's misconduct
occurred well after he' regained his
sopretty now thank the good Lord for
dogged Congressional Republicans who
fought hard to expose the truth and of
course the two IRS whistleblowers Gary
shapley and Joseph zegler who risked
their careers and the Wrath of the
federal government to tell the story of
coverup and Corruption hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else